Experimental self-driving vehicles
are taking to our streets, skies and seas
powered by artificial intelligence.
They might transport you around cities,
grow your food, or deliver packages to your doorstep.
They could reveal hidden glimpses of the
world around you
and even save lives.
They are designed to outperform humans
at specialised tasks, in very specific environments.
But they are not quite ready
to take full control.
Training their AI to interact safely with us in our
complex and unpredictable world
is still a significant challenge.
Deciding how and whether they should be used is another.
Self-driving vehicles use sensors and
artificial intelligence, or AI.
AI is what enables self-driving
vehicles to react in unpredictable situations.
This is an early example of British self-driving technology.
The car was modified by the road research laboratory,
which added an experimental automatic steering system.
The experiments were carried out on a specially adapted test track.
When the automatic steering mode was engaged, the driver could take their hands off the wheel.
This car was a prototype and was never commercially produced.
At the time, researchers estimated such systems could allow 50% more cars to drive on the roads,
while reducing accident rates.
Today, PODs are being used to help carry
passengers through airports and car parks.
This is an example that researchers are testing in Greenwich.
Where it could soon take visitors on a scenic journey around the peninsula.
Quiet and fully electric,  it's meant to operate in public spaces
alongside pedestrians, cyclists and animals.
Self-driving technology is being developed for many types of land vehicles.
From cars and trucks to military supply vehicles and robots that make deliveries
and farm crops.
'Tom' is the first prototype developed by the small robot company.
It can decide what route to take around
a field, photograph crops and tag their position on a map
It works alongside 'Dick' and 'Harry' which pull weeds and water the crops.
This data is sent to an artificial
intelligence-driven control system
called 'Wilma.'
Technology developers argue self-driving
vehicles could make journeys
faster, safer and more sustainable.
But some environments such as busy cities
are highly unpredictable and would need significant modifications to enable self-driving technology.
Your behaviour might have to change too.
Remote-controlled drones, piloted by
human operators, have been around for decades.
Now, experimental drones that fly themselves are taking to the skies.
Programming drones to fly on their own allows human operators to many at a time
and send them where humans cannot go.
As young boys in Afghanistan, brothers
Massoud and Mahmud Hassani
would make and race wind-powered toys.
Today,  their goal is to create an
unmanned de-mining system
that could clear the world's landmines within in 10 years.
Massoud first created
the Mine Kafon  ball 2011.
Roughly the height and weight of
a person,
the full-sized art piece catches enough
wind to roll it over minefields.
Detonating hidden landmines as it goes.
Many types of self-driving water
vehicles are in development.
From small ships that form footbridges
on demand
to massive cargo ships and military
vessels that hunt for hidden submarines.
Some are being developed to explore
challenging deep ocean environments
and beneath sea ice in polar regions.
In these extreme places, far beyond the
limits of human endurance and communication,
researchers must rely on these vehicles to take full control over their missions.
We know more about the surface of Mars
than our ocean floor.
These technologies could help make our world a smaller place.
They might also help us protect it.
This is a two-thirds scale model of the auto sub long-range vehicles.
engineers at The National Oceanography Centre have developed the ALR fleet to explore the deep ocean
and beneath polar ice,
collecting data on the causes and impacts of climate change.
Each ALR  is equipped with intelligent
navigation systems
to ensure they can operate independently
for months at a time,
up to six thousand metres under water
and two thousand kilometers away
before returning safely with valuable data.
Driverless cars have been a dream for decades but until now have mostly been science fiction.
This technology is developing quickly.
And in the coming years, we will increasingly see driverless cars and drones in our public spaces.
When that happens, we will all have decisions to make
about how we think these vehicles should be used.
And all of this will raise the question;
Who is in Control?